♪♪♪♪
-[ Gasps ]
[ Train whistle blowing ]
[ Heart beating ]
[ Groaning ]
[ Clock ticking ]
[ Click, ticking stops ]
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Joel Edgerton.
Obviously,
this is a television show,
but as the clip
would prove to anybody
or anyone who's watched it
it's so beautifully cinematic.
Did you even feel like
you were making a TV show
or just feel like a
big, long movie?
-It felt like, you know,
with Barry Jenkins at the helm
and James Laxton shooting it
that it was like a 10-hour movie
that we were making.
-Did you -- I mean, obviously,
you play a bad guy in this film,
but, yet, I heard it was
a role that you
sort of talked to
Barry about wanting.
Do you like the challenge
of playing a villain?
-Look, for years, I have bee
running around saying,
"I really want to
play villains,"
and I don't necessarily thin
I'm any good at it.
You know,
the idea as an actor is that
it's always going to be more fun
to play a villain.
And I heard about this project
and basically stalked
Barry about it.
And then I read the book,
and it's so --
The character I play, anyway
not necessarily the show
in its entirety,
but the character I play
is so evil and dark
that I started to go,
"Was this the right --
Should I have stalked him
before understanding
what the material was?"
Because it's
a pretty heavy character.
-Barry is a film director.
You're also a film director.
Yet, you sort of went up
and introduced yourself to Barry
with the hopes of getting cast
Does that work with you?
Do people ever, like, sidle up
to Joel Edgerton and say
they want to do
your next project?
-Look, I like ambitious people
You know what I mean?
Like, there's -- You know,
there's a time
and a place for it.
I don't know that I picked the
right time and place,
like, an evening event
in Toronto,
a couple of maybe
vodkas under my belt.
But, you know,
passion and ambition,
I think, are great traits.
And, you know,
it's good to put yourself
in a vulnerable position
and tell someone
that you really like their work.
And, you know,
you've got to give it a crack.
Crikey.
-Do you feel like, you know,
as someone who does
you know, both direct and act,
do you feel like
when you work with different
directors you respect,
you're always sort of taking
things with you
for the next time
you go behind the camera?
-Yeah. Look,
I think being on set
is like a
place to learn from...
As an actor, I learn from
directors I work with.
other actors I work with.
And, for example, in this show
I think it's also importan
to understand that you can
learn from children.
I have this incredible
relationship in the show
with a young actor called
Chase W. Dillon,
who plays Homer,
and you can
learn a lot from children.
I mean, if you keep your
eyes and your ears open,
you can steal from anybody
[ Laughter ]
-Colson Whitehead --
-Looking at you, Seth.
-[ Laughs ]
Colson, who's been on our show
and, you know, obviously
is brilliant, and I know,
from Barry, he visited set
What's it like
when someone, you know,
who creates the source materia
comes on while you're
doing the adaptation?
-When Colson came on set,
it was --
For me, it felt like the C.E.O
had entered the building.
There was an incredible amount
of respect, appreciation
for what he'd created that
allowed us all,
hundreds of people, to be there,
and a desire to want him
to feel good about everything,
like the sets, the costume
And particularly for me,
I'm like,
"Do I fill the shoes of
the character
that you created in
your own private space?"
So it felt like, you know --
It felt like a good, cool C.E.O.
had entered the building.
-Alright, now,
I need to ask you this
just because I know
you're back in Australia.
How long has it been
since you were at the beach?
-Two days.
-Okay.
-Yeah, no, like, I go for
a swim or a surf most days
but I have been
a little bit busy lately.
-Yeah. Fatherhood will do that
It will take away -- It will cut
into your beach time.
-It's about three minutes
that way on foot.
And I have a garage
full of surfboards.
Listen, man, we're very luck
here in Australia.
-Yeah.
-We're able to move around
The country's handled it
very well,
and we feel very blessed.
And for that reason,
we're allowed to go and mingle
at the beach and
go to restaurants and stuff.
So, you know, we're very lucky
-Well, I'm very happy
to hear that.
Please continue to
enjoy it all safely.
Congrats again on fatherhood
and it's always
so nice to see you, buddy.
-You too, mate.
It's always good to see you.
Thank you. Thank you.
-You're very welcome.
"The Underground Railroad"
is now streaming on
Amazon Prime Video.